but you know what it feels like that
documentary we saw tickled
we you guys saw a documentary on I saw
it on iTunes and said tickled and
anything that says that I go I want to
watch it love being tickled I think it's
I think it's fun you know when I when I
pin kalila down I start tickling her as
you go stop it's like legal rape look at
me it's torture is what I'm saying
torture Anstey but but we're also
laughing so it seems like people are
having fun but you're really controlling
somebody can I give him a quick synopsis
tickle well yeah go ahead
so basically the documentary starts off
with this reporter from New Zealand
trying to get more information about the
new sport of quote/unquote competitive
tickling that's so he wrote the
organisation yeah so he right you see
got you so he he comes upon is that the
right way to say it I can't even talk
well he writes this and he sees it right
he sees like a group of people wearing
adidas guys right adidas wear and
they're being tied up and three other
guys on top of this guy and just
tickling him stop stop right we're at
court yeah it's a sport so well no no
supposedly it's a sport a sport
yeah supposedly so this guy right then
and there response he got was complete
and it was like a an organization called
like is it Jane O'Brien or something
like that yeah it was like this media
company called Jane O'Brien and he
contacts them saying that I would love
to do documentary about about
competitive oh yeah we're like do a
piece on it on this news show that I do
and they said no because you're gay and
you're a [ __ ] yeah you're a [ __ ]
you're this and that which other he and
he's like well this is gay what you're
doing yeah yeah it's so gay right and so
he obviously when he reads that it
becomes more interesting red flag for
him it's like why is this guy so
defensive about me writing a piece on
competitive tickly which is like
just in the innocent documentary of just
fun surface it quite possibly is
probably one of the darkest documents
yes absolutely why he opens up wormhole
and he dives in it and it is dark it's
not like weird and I made Sebastian
Maniscalco and his wife watch it and
they loved it so people really when I
recommend it they really like it
I would really watch it because it is
some weird [ __ ] but if when you say dark
just like a about the people involved it
will give you a little bit insight into
what people with money can do Oh is
there a destroy lives well not even yeah
it's yes it just it has not yes you know
with actual tickling no it has to do
with knowing has to do with this is um
imagine me right they'll give it away
don't give it away police donned okay
please just have him watch it because it
does take a really weird turn yeah it
took it takes a really dark turn I
sometimes wish that life would give us
gifts like that because the guide the
guy had no intention of Rhett making a
documentary until he got that reply back
on Facebook like [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
[Music]